let's have a look at it shall we now
they provide this substitution I'll say
right from the outset they're bit sneaky
in the way that they do this I'll and
the answers in particular they lack a
lot of detail particularly with regard
to restrictions okay when they use this
substitution and introduce it then make
a whole bunch of assumptions about the
restrictions that they'd never resolved
really but I want you now to think about
the way we set it up and what we finally
end up with I wonder if you can
determine what the restrictions are look
that complicated but you should address
it okay so they've started us off with
this and in order to make a substitution
obviously you'll need a derivative right
so we're going to do the X on your feet
up and that's going to give you well
it's a sine theta or square right so
you're just doing your normal chain rule
right you can do the inside the inside
function sine so spirit of is cos and
then you do the outside it's something
squared so the power comes out the front
and you reduce the power by one there
you go
to sin theta cos theta you might be
tempted to put that into on double angle
formula okay so you can see that sine 2
theta but you may be able to say that
when you bring this back over here it's
not gonna actually be any advantage to
you just simplify it in that way and use
that identity ok good so we've got that
in place
do I need any other pieces in order to
subs as you this in it looks like air to
me I think we can start going on this so
this is going to be equal to and we'll
do all of us of Decision all at once
okay we're gonna get a square root of
sine squared on 1 minus sine squared
okay now that DX here that's going to be
your place by 2 sine theta cos theta
d-theta right training off there
okay and you can see it clearly we can
do some canceling here but you have to
be careful because of the restrictions
and the cases that you need to introduce
interview right so your sites man over
there your denominator of course is
going to be closed square so you're at
the square root of sine square on cos
square you might be tempted to turn it
into ten but based on what I have over
here there's kind of no much point is
there okay now this is kind of the line
that the textbook goes through when it
gets its answer I know because of how it
simplifies it out but strictly speaking
this the square root of science penico
square it's not exactly sign on close is
it
that's the difference what's been missed
it really should be an absolute value
around these should that because by
definition this thing it has to be
positive right because it's a square
root yeah
so really this should be this front the
question sorry the answer doesn't
address that though as you see why it's
just going to simplify out I just want
you to be mindful of the fact that when
you evaluate this square root of a
square number you're always gonna get
something positive it's absolute value
regardless what happens here you can see
that the because is it going to cancel
right so what are we gonna get you're
gonna get the integral of 2 sine squared
okay now suggestions what can we do with
this thing you've met this before you've
been in three years haven't you
what can we do ah now double angle right
so two sine squared theta you want to
get this in terms of close to theta just
over on the side you might note down cos
2theta we're going to use the 1 minus 1
minus 2 sine squared it up form of the
identity right that's kind of convenient
that it's already a 2 there these guys
just need to swap places don't they -
sine squared is 1 - close to thena ok
so therefore I can put that back into
here okay
and I'm kind of done right I can I can
deal with this
what's the one going to turn into just
yeah
what's the close to thea gonna turn into
- ah sign to pick up that check out you
can check you can integrate it back so I
differentiate it back and you should end
up with posted because that's two and a
half Quetzal all good okay so now I've
resolved my integral but I'm not done
yet
why not it's it's all I'm feeders
right which are foreign to the question
we introduced the theatres in order to
get it into a form that was easier to
work with but now we've got to get rid
of them okay so you have some problems
your x equals science squared theater
that was the solution they introduced
okay I don't have those here okay
so what I need to do is nothing to twist
and turn this thing in order to get
these pieces out right so for example if
you want to feed our what would you do
feed on its own out of this
well for starters this this thing's
squared right side own front squared I'm
going to need to take the square root of
both sides
okay now the textbook does this it just
assumes that but of course you can't
really can you because what is it really
equal to it's equal to plus minus right
so you see what I mean the next one just
gives you the answer in the in every
integral it's one of the primitives but
it doesn't account for all of the cases
right so they just deal with this and
they say therefore theta is equal to
sine inverse which again if you've taken
sine inverse of both sides again
introduces another restriction right
though he's super careful so I can at
least put that into there that's good I
haven't dealt with the sine two theta
but what do I do with that
now we saw the sine 2 theta here so
we're like well that's the X on D Peter
but that's the help that's still got
leaders in it okay so what kinds of
options do we have
well I know what sine theta is right and
there's a sine theta
hiding in the sine two theta right what
identity can I use you to help me this
is double angle right these are still
there this part here is two sine theta
cos theta so the two and a half that's
just this okay is this better or worse
it is a bit better because at least I
know what sine is right so I could deal
with that but I don't know what causes
do i ah if we know sine we know cause
okay because cos is defined off a song
so there's a couple different ways to go
about this probably the most direct way
is to come back to this guy this tells
you based on the fact that now I'm only
considering this within a certain domain
like a very very restrictive domain I
can draw a triangle off of this right
angle triangle like so okay if I put
feeder over here what does this ratio
tell me about any of the science what
can I put on their sign is opposite on
hypotenuse isn't it opposite on
hypotenuse that's rude X and that's one
okay so that would make this side down
here by Pythagoras the square root of 1
minus X all right yeah cuz you square
these both and you have any other year
the hypotenuse
good so therefore out of this
I get that cos theta is adjacent over
hypotenuse which is the square root of 1
minus X they go if you know a sign you
can get cos Alex supposing you're within
the restricted domain okay so now I've
got all my pieces saying this reacts
just taking that positive case - now
there's sine theta and there's cos theta
they're both square roots aren't they so
I can just put the square root over the
whole thing like so there's an X and
there's 1 minus X plus C now like I said
so crazy restrict something very Seuss's
on this right well X is what's positive
because I did this trip up here and
assume that sine inverse of sine theta
cos theta
I'm only between 0 and pi/2 so it
happens that this integral only works
for or it only exists for a very very
small area right but sure enough if you
differentiate it back you get the square
root of x 1 1 minus x eventually okay